is that ronnie dangerfield i can't quite
see your shirt it is right over there
now i can see it yeah
now i can see the checkered suit yeah
um uh i was going to make a joke but let
me just jump on in so i've seen uh first
of all i want to start by saying how
much i've enjoyed your work in these
spider-man movies like everyone um out
there um
i've seen the opening like whatever
amount of time of this new movie and
it's so good and you have so much to do
how much fun was it uh like filming this
third installment because it seems like
anyway it just seems like it's been a
blast
it's always great to be with john watts
i love him i trust him so much as a
director and he is is he's so brilliant
and so fun to be around so with each
installment i get to know him a little
better and we get to even explore
more ideas ideas that we had from the
beginning that might happen later or if
we we can pick up threads together since
we've had these three films together
how much did you actually get told when
you first signed on about like the arc
of you know may or was it sort of like
you know filmed by film you've been
learning well
yeah i mean it's not exactly what i was
told from the beginning but it's turned
out okay
how early on did they tell you about the
multiverse did you know when you were
making the last one that this was coming
uh no
no no no no
i don't i
no
that stuff is so top secret i i yeah i'm
not i'm i'm not
told about that stuff till the
until it has to be revealed to me
i i understand um i the thing that uh
these movies are so massive in scale and
scope i don't think people really
realize who are just like casual fans
what really goes on behind the scenes to
make that something like this come to
life
could you like sort of talk about what
do you think might surprise people to
learn about the making of a spider-man
movie
well
it's surprising it was surprising to me
to hear john watts say i want to treat
this like an independent film we're just
just going to be us our little ensemble
of actors and that's how we're going to
treat this that's what the vibe is going
to be like and it is it's very loose he
keeps a very loose set a very
improvisational set uh
a lot of um character development
and things that happen in in small
indies
where i'm comfortable and where he's
comfortable
and
so
yet he can hold the scope of the epic
technological feats and things like that
but but
it was surprising to me for him to
approach it that way and that it works
that way
one of the things uh on all movies
things change like the script changes a
lot you can have a rainbow by the end of
the production how much has the
spider-man scripts changed during the
making of all three films or has it been
kind of stable
yeah i i'm not really privy to a lot of
that but i know that there were some
sets that were built and then were
discarded and other things were built in
their stead so i think that things
things do change and and evolve because
the world at the world we're all living
in is changing can you imagine that what
what the plot line
was two years before the pandemic or
what people were thinking as this might
unfold but you have to react the writers
um and creators and people at marvel
have to think about well what's going on
in the world what do people want to talk
about or hear about or react to and
we've all
the whole planet earth has been through
so many changes
and so
what's amazing is that um
the the spider-man series has kept up
with that
i have to stop there again i want to say
thank you so much for your work as this
character i've really loved it thank you
for your time thanks so much
you